la prensa china sostiene hoy que si sin
fin la habría advertido a job aiden de
que debe tratar con mucho tacto temas
como xinjiang
hong kong o taiwán porque todos ellos
son asuntos que afectan a la integridad
territorial china y esa es la
tradicional línea roja de beijing xi
jinping también le habría dicho a job
aiden que la cooperación es la única vía
para solventar conflictos que son no
sólo ayudar a ambos países sino al mundo
entero y que la confrontación sólo
conduce al desastre la prensa china ha
hecho una valoración muy positiva de la
llamada que ambos líderes han mantenido
esta mañana recuerda la vieja relación
que mantienen y se congratula de que
china y eeuu hayan recuperado canales de
comunicación que habían quedado
arrasados durante el mandato de donald
trump también valora que la llamada se
haya producido coincidiendo con el año
nuevo chino lo que es interpretado no
sólo como un gesto de respeto hacia sí
sin pin sino hacia todo el pueblo chino
y por último también se congratula de
que joe biden haya definido las
relaciones bilaterales
de competición pero no necesariamente de
conflicto